omicron continue de déferler sur la
russie depuis deux semaines la courbe
des contaminations quotidienne au
comique 19 grimpe à la verticale passant
de 15000 le 10 janvier à plus de 80
milles ce jeudi 27 janvier un chiffre
inquiétant certes mais celui des
nouvelles hospitalisations qui aussi
actuellement autour de 12000 reste le
plus important pour les autorités je
vous propose d'écouter le porte parole
du kremlin à ce sujet
malheureusement ni le président ni
personne d'autre ne peuvent intervenir
face au processus de propagation du
virus omicron
prendre des mesures qui arrêterait la
propagation de mikron est impossible
physiquement
et si vous avez noté la récente logique
du centre opérationnel du gouvernement
dans le cas de mikron sans tenir compte
du fait que cette forme de la maladie a
en général des formes plus légère il est
beaucoup plus important de suivre la
dynamique des hospitalisations et du
niveau d'occupation des lits dans les
régions
dans la capitale aussi en surveille de
près l'impact du virus sur les hôpitaux
ici omicron représente 80 % des nouveaux
cas mais compte tenu de sa gravité
moindre par rapport à celle du variant
delta la mairie de moscou espère éviter
une surcharge des services hospitaliers
le nombre de personnes sous ventilateur
n'a presque pas augmenté au cours des
deux dernières semaines en raison du
fait que le variant omicron continue de
remplacer le delta
nous pensons qu'il n'y aura peut-être
pas de changement majeur quant à la
pression sur les services hospitaliers
non mais évidemment compte tenu de
l'expérience que nous observons de ce
qui se passe dans le monde pendant au
moins encore deux semaines il y aura une
croissance du taux de contamination
boudé
les autorités de la capitale ont d'ores
et déjà annoncé que l'introduction de
restriction dépendrait de l'évolution du
taux d'incidence et d'hospitalisation et
les moscovites que pense-t-il les
derniers chiffres
et à dans mon stand
good to be rich iott
votre spec je pense que cette pandémie
va progresser mais qu'elle va bientôt
s'atténuer j'y crois je pense que tout
ira bien je pense que oui on a besoin de
mesures supplémentaires dans la
situation que vit la russie en ce moment
je pense que c'est très compliqué de les
mettre en oeuvre parce qu'on n'aime pas
quand il ya des interdictions
tout le monde a peur des qr codes de
toutes ces restrictions il me semble que
les gens sont fatigués de ces
restrictions et les entreprises en
particulier est bénite chen ying lu tim
uppal tojo star à la tête du congrès ni
de chénier et e-business
en fait la situation ne semble vraiment
pas si simple elle est alarmante car à
en juger par l'entreprise où je
travaille nous subissons une vraie
réduction du nombre des membres du
personnel et donc ça signifie qu'il ya
vraiment des maladies je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il s'agisse du comité 19 ou d'autres
maladies mais on ne peut pas le nier
alors il faut prendre des mesures car on
constate que c'est très contagieux
peut-être que pour l'économie le
confinement n'est pas une bonne chose
bien sûr mais je crois que le contrôle
plus strict du port des masques et de
toutes sortes d'équipements de
protection est nécessaire
près de la moitié des 12 millions de
moscovites ont reçu une première dose du
vaccin pour intensifier le rythme de la
vaccination qu'elle juge actuellement
insuffisants les autorités ont décidé
d'ouvrir prochainement celle ci aux
adolescents à partir de 12 ans